es la otan confirma que según Las
investigaciones preliminares el misil
que cayó ayer en territorio o polaco y
que mató a dos personas se trata de un
misil de la defensa antiaérea ucraniana
que es que se desvió a territorio polaco
mientras intentaba defender al
territorio ucraniano de los bombardeos
que se produjeron a todo lo largo del
día de ayer en todo el territorio
ucraniano Estas son las principales
conclusiones a las que han llegado hoy
Los embajadores tras ser llamados a
consultas hoy en una reunión de urgencia
en Bruselas aquí han escuchado al
embajador polaco en que ha informado
sobre cuál es la situación en el terreno
el secretario general de la otan James
toltenberg que insiste en que este
ataque no es culpa de Ucrania que esto
no ocurriría en cualquier caso si Rusia
no hubiese invadido a Ucrania y trata de
exculpar a el gobierno de kiev este
incidente Era uno de los grandes te
desde que empezó la guerra hace ya nueve
meses que realmente un incidente de este
tipo pudiera afectar a territorio Aliado
y este incidente según stoltenberg
demuestra la delicada situación y la
gravedad de la guerra en Ucrania y como
esto puede afectar realmente a
territorio Aliado y de hecho por ello en
la Cumbre de Madrid del pasado junio los
líderes europeos apoyaron reportadas
reforzar todo el flanco Oriental para
evitar incidentes de este como el que ha
ocurrido ayer en cualquier caso he
preguntado el secretario general de la
otan sobre la posibilidad de que el
escudo de antimisiles de la alianza no
haya funcionado no haya funcionado el
secretario general de la otan insiste en
que tendrían que producirse un ataque
deliberado con unas características y
unas incidencias que no se produjeron
porque el ataque de ayer Parece ser que
no fue deliberado y que todas las
conclusiones por el momento demuestran
que ni siquiera Rusia planificando en
ningún caso ningún ataque a territorio
Aliado